- [Voiceover] What I wanna
do in this video is get
a little bit familiar with
the idea of molecular mass.
Let's start off with a molecule that
we're all quite familiar with.
In fact, we are made
up of this molecule or
to a large degree, made
up of this molecule.
That is water and the molecular
formula for water is H2O.
Every water molecule
has two hydrogen atoms
and one oxygen atom.
What I'm curious about is, what is
the mass of a molecule of water?
So, the way that you might
think about doing that is,
what's the mass of each of the hydrogens?
You're gonna have two of those and then
what's the mass of the oxygen?
That would be a reasonable way to do it.
So, what is a mass of the hydrogen?
A hydrogen has a mass...
We can go to a periodic table here,
I've got one right over here.
You see hydrogen, it has
its atomic number one.
That's the number of protons,
that's what makes it hydrogen.
Then down here you have this number.
I think you can see, it's a
little bit small probably,
on your screen, it says, "1.0079".
This right over here is the
atomic weight of hydrogen.
This is, if you take the
various isotopes of hydrogen
on the planet earth and you
take the weighted average.
So the ones that are more
common, they are weighted higher.
The weighted average
of their atomic masses
is 1.0079.
Now for the sake of this
first pass, we're just going
to say, "It's roughly one
atomic mass unit." and one way
to think about it...
This isn't precise and it's
not how things are defined,
but it is a useful way to think about
atomic mass or mass on the atomic scale.
Is that one neutron,
or one proton
have an atomic mass of approximately
one atomic mass unit.
In other videos we'll talk
about why it's not defined
this way and why it's based on the
carbon-12 isotope and all of that.
But this is a fairly useful
thing that is helpful
to think about, what is the
atomic mass likely to be?
What is it roughly?
When you see that hydrogen,
it has one proton.
Clearly, that's what makes it hydrogen.
It also has an atomic mass of
one or roughly one, it says,
"Well, it must not have a neutron."
That is the case, the most
common isotope of hydrogen
on earth is just a proton with a electron.
The electron also does contribute to mass
but it's negligible
compared to the proton.
Most of this mass is
essentially the proton.
A little bit of the
electron and also kind of
the weighted average, when you think about
the other isotopes of
hydrogen that maybe might
have a neutron that is involved with it.
For the sake of this, we could say,
"Hey, hydrogen, it's a
proton with an electron
"kind of buzzing around it."
It is approximately one
atomic mass unit,
and then oxgen.
Oxygen, same idea, we'll
look at the periodic table.
You could guess what its mass is close to.
Oxygen, the most typical isotope of oxygen
that you'll see on
earth has eight protons.
The eight protons are
what makes it oxygen.
Any oxygen has to have
eight protons anywhere
that you are in the
universe, if it doesn't have
eight protons it's not oxygen.
It's gonna have eight
protons and it's gonna have
eight neutrons, that's the
most typical isotope of oxygen.
So you might guess that its atomic mass
is 16 atomic mass units.
You can see that your
guess is pretty good.
When we look at our atomic
weight right over here.
Which is the weighted
average of the various
isotopes of oxygen as found on earth.
You get 15.999, which
is pretty close to 16.
Our approximation to 16 is pretty good.
Then based on these numbers
you would say that this H2O
has an atomic mass of approximately...
Well, two from the hydrogens,
where did I get the two from?
Each of these two hydrogens
have an atomic mass of one.
If you have two times
one, it's just gonna be
two atomic mass units.
Then 16 from the oxygen.
Two plus 16,
which is going to get us...
Let me do this in another
color, since I've been using...
It's going to give us 18
atomic mass units.
Now, if you wanted to be more precise
or if you wanted to say,
"Well, I have this big bag
"of water, I'm not looking
exactly at one water molecule.
"What is going to be, on average,
"the mass of those water molecules?"
It might be helpful to get
a little it more precise.
Then it is helpful, especially
if you're talking about a
large number of molecules
and you really just wanna
take the weighted average
of all of those molecules.
Then it makes sense to say, "Well, let's
"use the atomic weight."
So for hydrogen, the atomic weight was
1.0079.
Which is, once again,
1.0079 atomic mass units.
We call it atomic weight
but it's really just
the weighted average, it's not weight in
kind of the physics sense
of measuring a force.
So, 1.0079 atomic mass
units and the oxygen is
is 15.999
atomic mass units and if
you wanted to get a more
precise number here, let's
get a calculator out.
I got my calculator.
I'm gonna have two times
1.0079
is equal to, and then to
that I'm gonna add, plus
15.999.
Gets us to...
Let's see, I should go no more than
three decimal places to the right.
Since I added this, if I don't wanna
add precision here...
If you wanna a review
of that, you should look
at the video on significant figures.
Since I added something
with just three decimals to
to the right I shouldn't
have more than three decimals
in my answer so, 18.01,
I'll round in the thousandths place,
015.
So the real one is 18.015
atomic mass units.
You could actually consider
this the molecular weight.
Because once again, we're
using atomic weights.
We're using weighted average
and you could think of,
maybe the weighted
average of water molecules
would be a little bit closer to this.
These two numbers are very close.
So we might call this
molecular weight.
Either way, these ideas
are very closely related.
When we're thinking on the atomic scale,
when people use the word
weight, they're not using
it like a force like
you use in physics that
you would measure in newtons or pounds.
They are essentially taking a
weighted average of masses.
So the molecular weight of
water, 18.015 atomic mass units.
If you wanted to just kinda
be a little bit loosey goosey,
you could say it's roughly
18 atomic mass units.